[Musik]
hallo alle zusammen
ich hab euch ja schon mal meinen maxi
king in xxl gezeigt und heute habe ich
für euch einen maxi king cab torte
wie schmeckt unfassbar lecker und ich
empfehle sie wirklich jedem nachzumachen
für die krebs benötigen wir acht eier
310 gramm mehl 900 milliliter lauwarme
milch 110 gramm flüssige butter 50 gramm
zucker und einem teelöffel vanille
extrakten und der teig ist auch sehr
schnell hergestellt als erstes werden
die eier mit dem zucker und dem wandel
der extrakt laboriert
[Musik]
und danach wird die flüssige butter
untergerührt
danach kommt auch schon die milch dazu
und achtet am besten darauf dass
demnächst lauwarm ist und generell die
ganzen zutaten zimmertemperatur haben
damit es am ende keine klümpchen gibt
und danach kommt auch das mädchen zu und
das lied ich zur sicherheit damit ich
keine klümpchen im teig ab
[Musik]
nachdem auch das klappt so wird wurde
ist der clip zeigt schon fertig jetzt du
springst meinen heiße skripnik noch mit
bakterien spray und wer kein fett make
up zu hause hat der kann natürlich auch
eine pfanne benutzten
die caps werden jetzt von beiden seiten
zwei minuten lang ausgebacken
diesen klub make-up verwende ich
übrigens schon wird über zwei jahren und
ich bin sehr zufrieden
der bug gleichmäßig war sehr günstig und
erfüllt einfach sein zweck ich verlinke
euch dann nochmal einen link in der
infobox
[Musik]
und während die caps abkühlen machen wir
schon mal die maxi king kleben dafür
benötigen wir 400 milliliter sahne 80
gramm puderzucker 500 gramm mascarpone
50 gramm magermilchpulver und neun
teelöffel seiner partei zuallererst wird
die berne mit vier teelöffel in seiner
partei schlagen in einer anderen schüsse
müssen wir dann was capone und
puderzucker miteinander
[Musik]
dort kommt dann noch das restliche
seiner party nein
[Musik]
danach geht die sonne unter gehoben
jetzt gebe ich noch dass
magermilchpulver hinzu und verrührt das
noch mal
das könnt ihr natürlich auch schon
vorher zum auftakt ohne geben das hab
ich leider vergessen
nun kann die torte auch schon
geschichtet werden dazu lege ich mir
meine abgekühlten tipps bereit die creme
und karamellsoße dafür gebe ich mir
immer jeweils einen cap auf meine
tortenplatte und verstreicht ihr dann
etwa von der creme daraus
[Musik]
und darüber verteidigt dann von meiner
karamell
[Musik]
wenn wir dann alle klubgeschichte habt
dann nehmt euch einen keller vorhand und
schneidet die ränder ab
[Musik]
und die reste wurden dann einfach so
gegessen sie dürfe auf keinen fall
wegschmeißen
[Musik]
das rezept ist übrigens so ausgelegt
dass ihr dann mit einem wecker 26
zentimeter große torte machen können ihr
müsst natürlich nicht so viel von der
keb torte abschneiden wie ich hier im
video
aber ich wollte die torte unbedingt auf
meiner neuen tortenplatte präsentieren
und da hat leider nicht so viel drauf
verpasst
und jetzt gebe ich die torte nochmals
durch kühlen für 30 minuten in den
kühlschrank für die schoko jawohl nehme
ich mir 200 gramm fett peter kuvertüre
und vermische sie mit 50 gramm koks
anschließend nämlich die torte auf dem
kühlschrank verteile die kuvertüre
darüber und streiche alles klappt und
[Musik]
wenn die glasur auch schon angetrocknet
ist dann könnt ihr noch nach belieben
dekorieren
klasse an den seiten noch etwas aktiver
kuvertüre unter pfiffen und gäbe dann
meine maxime es drauf
[Musik]
ihr könnt dafür so dekorieren wie es
euch am besten gefällt da sind der
fantasie keine grenzen gesetzt
die capt worte die schmeckt total nach
maxi king tut an meinen gefallen und
gibt nach euren freunden ohne
didaktischen deko drauf und fragt nach
was sie schmeckt die werden antworten
das schmeckt 100 prozent nach maxi king
und ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken